mindy's working hard on it i know she is
and she's she and i just love each other
we have a great laugh just thinking
about what would l woods be doing right
now reese witherspoon shares an update
on legally blonde three
what like it's hard e.t recently caught
up with reese and jennifer aniston to
talk about the upcoming second season of
their hit apple tv show the morning show
i just need a minute please i need to
talk to you right now
where are you going
and reece gave an update on the highly
anticipated third installment of legally
blonde which is being co-written by
mindy kaling and dan gore legally blonde
three we know what's in the works have
you seen a sneak peek of mindy kaling's
script i know it is under lock and key
super secretive but give us something to
go off of we don't have a script yet
reese what are you thinking girlfriend
well she's a little busy by the way
mindy's busy i'm a bit bit mindy's
working hard on it i know she is and
she's she and i just love each other we
have a great laugh just thinking about
what would elle woods be doing right now
it's funny crazy to revisit and play
that character again i know how is she
different today
i don't know and something so many
things have changed but then some things
are just so
similar
back in may 2020 when the news was
announced reese tweeted her excitement
writing in part quote great news alert
some things are just meant to be and at
the time mindy expressed her excitement
at the chance to work with her wrinkle
and time co-star again on instagram
adding quote l woods is so iconic
proving you can be girly and smart at
the same time bend and snap people
so you bend
and snap
the oscar-winning actress will reprise
her role as l woods the sorority
president turned harvard law graduate
she created in the original 2001 flick
hi i'm elle woods and this is freezer
woods
and we're both gemini vegetarians reece
first confirmed that illegally blonde 3
was in the works in 2018 channeling her
inner l on instagram alongside the
caption quote it's true
hey l do you know what happened on days
of our lives yesterday why yes margo i
do and while fans of legally blonde will
just have to wait to see elle back on
the big screen they can check out rhys
on the new season of the morning show
when the first episode drops friday
in case you forgot i'm the whistleblower
i'm gonna get everything i want and when
e.t chatted with rhys and jen they
opened up about how the show will
address the ongoing covid19 pandemic
we have all lived through the insanity
of 2020 so when exactly did you decide
to rework the season to really include
covet and things and how challenging was
it to have to relive it when we locked
down
is when we realized that we had to go
back to the drawing board and figure out
how do we incorporate this into
the show
and also
figure out how to
sort of delicately weave it through
because
we didn't know where we would be at
when the show aired if we were out of
covid and would people be fatigued by
hearing about kovid it was interesting
and again watching all of the news shows
try to figure it out as a show about a
new show watching them all try to figure
out in real time how do we handle this
new normal
[Music]